Today, we're going to be speaking with Jean
Guerrero, who's author of Hate Monger Stephen
Miller, Donald Trump and the White Nationalist
Agenda.
Great to have you on, Jean.
Great to be here.
So first, just to start with, before we get
into really the substance, if people don't
know who Steven Miller is, if they pay attention
to the things Trump says, a lot of those come
from the mind of Steven Miller and sometimes
from the pen of Steven Miller.
But who who is this guy?
How did he get involved with Donald Trump?
Exactly.
You know, Steven Miller is not only one of
Trump's top speechwriters, he is also the
immigration policy architect.
So he's a senior policy adviser for Trump
with a major focus on the immigration issue.
But you see him shaping his rhetoric on pretty
much everything.
And he is a Jewish American who comes from
Santa Monica, California.
And he got involved with the Trump campaign
after working with Alabama Senator Jeff Sessions
and various other people in Congress for a
little while and really becoming interested
in, you know, a person who who he felt was
was not politically correct and who gave voice
to a lot of the feelings that he'd had ever
since he was a teenager.
You know, Steven Miller, from the time that
he was a teenager in Santa Monica, he would
go around his his height, his very diverse
high school, telling his Mexican classmates
to go back to their countries, telling them
to speak English.
He broke up with a Mexican friend, telling
him he couldn't be friends with someone with
a Latino heritage.
So he was he was from a very young age expressing
these kinds of beliefs.
When and when he heard Trump talking about
Mexicans as rapists and criminals, he got
very excited and started to contribute free
labor to his campaign in the form of talking
points in the form of immigration policies
and eventually got hired.
What how does someone like Stephen Miller
end up given where he was born and given.
I mean, you know, as as a Jewish Latino American
myself, I can say that your Jews in the United
States are very reliably left wing group,
75, 80, even 85 percent support of Democratic
presidents in the past.
I don't I'm involved in all sorts of national
Jewish groups.
I've never met anyone who would even consider
working for someone like Jeff Sessions, who,
even if for Jewish Republicans, would be almost
too far to really get involved in.
How does a California guy like this end up
with these beliefs?
We'll do it.
I really see it as a case study in radicalization.
And, you know, when he was a teenager, he
was going through a very hard time.
His family had lost a lot of money related
to their real estate company.
They had to move from a very affluent part
of Santa Monica to a slightly less affluent
and more diverse part.
Steven Miller ends up having to go to a public
high school instead of a mostly white private
high school.
And, you know, during this time period, he
meets this man named David Horowitz, who is
a former Marxist turned right wing radical
who was writing things at the time about how
the only real racism is racism against white
men, that racism against black and brown people
is a figment of your imagination, that everything
that we hold dear in society as Americans
is a result of white men, things like justice,
equality, freedom, that these are all things
to white men.
And so these are ideas that he introduced
Steven Miller to.
He ends up becoming like a father figure to
Steven Miller and teaching him the weapons
of the civil rights movement as a person who
came from the left in order to attack the
civil rights movement.
So he taught Steven Miller how to invert and
deflect the language of the left, casting
white men as victims of discrimination based
on their skin color, casting people of color
as the real racists or the real oppressors.
And this is language that Steven Miller used
throughout his career.
David Horowitz got him his first jobs in Congress,
first with Tea Party Congresswoman Michele
Bachmann and then with John Shadegg of Arizona
and finally with Jeff Sessions of Alabama.
And Buddy Buddy introduced him to these really
white supremacist ideas on how to launder
them through the language of heritage and
the language of national security and the
language of economics in order to make these
ideas palatable to the mainstream does.
Stephen Miller has been doing it in the speeches
of Donald Trump and over the course of his
his time working for him.
This question might apply more generally than
just to Stephen Miller, but there's this incredible
irony of someone who is part of a group that
was not considered white by the white European
oppressors for so long.
Right.
Jews were the whole much anti Semitic discrimination
is based on the air that Jews are not white,
jumping in full bore to repeat the talking
points that were essentially used against
Jews.
That that that's really probably a broader
phenomena that we see among some on the right.
Exactly.
You know, he takes ideas directly from white
nationalist and white supremacist literature.
This has been documented.
You know, emails I've reviewed of has strategy
papers that he's worked on.
And these are groups that not only vilify
and promote violence against people of color,
but they feel the same way about the Jewish
people.
And it's a it's a real conflict that exists
inside of Steven Miller.
Most of his family is appalled at what he's
doing in the White House.
As far as the rhetoric and the policy switch
largely target immigrants who are fleeing
persecution and violence in their home countries.
You know, Steven Miller's grandmother on his
mother's side, Ruth.
She spent her retirement compiling the family
history so that Steven Miller and her other
grandchildren would never forget the value
of people who come to this country and nothing
but the clothes on their back and speaking
no English, which is how Steven Miller's great
grandparents came here from Eastern Europe
fleeing persecution, fleeing nationalist agitators
in Eastern Europe.
And she also recorded for him the lessons
of of, you know, the dangers of demonization.
And these are lessons that most people in
the Jewish community, you know, value and
understand how important they are.
But there are lessons that Steven Miller,
from the time that he he was young, has been
not only ignoring but but directly attacking.
And it's worth noting that his mentor, David
Horowitz, is also, you know, a Jewish man.
And he you know, he's he he's sort of his
entry way into white nationalist ideologies,
which he would you know, he he constantly
says he's not a white nationalist.
He's not a racist.
But if you look at his his writings, they're
very much echoing these white nationalist
talking points.
But he but anyway, he he he starts out with
this very A.I.
Palestine and high Arab anti-Muslim mentality.
And eventually, you know, Steve Miller broadens
that out to include all all immigrants.
But this is why you saw one of the first actions
that he took in the White House was the Muslim
ban.
And then eventually, you know, the systematic
separation of migrant children from their
parents and the systematic dismantling of
the asylum system at the U.S. Mexico border
and the destruction of the refugee admissions
system as it exists in the United States.
Most of these policies have impacted people
seeking legal pathways into this country because
they are desperate, because, you know, they're
facing death threats at home.
This is not about criminals and cartels crossing
the border, sneaking across the border illegally.
And Stephen Miller's policies disproportionately
impact families who are trying to do things
the legal way.
Because that is not M.S. 13, as Donald Trump
often likes to talk about at rallies.
Well, and that's something that Stephen Miller
inserts into Trump's speeches.
He knows that M.S. 13, he is like this, you
know, thing the symbol that he can use to
rally people around policies that harm families
overall.
But, yeah, I mean, the reason that these policies
work this way is because he's pulling them
directly from think tanks created by a man
named John Tanton, a eugenicist who believed
in population control for nonwhite people,
a white supremacist who believes in the genetic
superiority of whites.
And these think tanks like the Federation
for American Immigration Reform, you know,
they they seem innocuous.
They have very banal sounding intellectual
names.
But they exist to to weed to find ways to
dismantle legal pathways into this country
for people from Latin America and Africa.
So to zoom out a little bit.
Very often when the topic of the Trump administration
and Trump's rhetoric and white nationalism
comes up, you will hear these sort of reflexive
defenses about Trump's son in law is Jewish
and his, you know, daughter converted, his
grandkids are Jewish in that type of thing.
When I interviewed white nationalist Richard
Spencer years ago during the Trump administration,
he said that he doesn't expect Trump to actually
come out and say things exactly the way he
says them, but that he sees Trump as sort
of like the closest thing to his ideology,
although more recently, Spencer himself has
said they're kind of done with Trump and OK,
fine, we can move past that.
But, Mike, my question more broadly is what
are the ways in which Donald Trump's language
may be even unknown to Trump because it's
being inserted by Miller?
Doesn't matter.
What are the ways in which Trump has sort
of signaled to these groups that at least
to some degree, he's their guy?
Well, start with the more recent example.
I mean, Trump, for his real strategy, has
been really working.
Conflate anti-racist protesters and Black
Lives Matter protesters with, quote, agitators
and anarchists and mobs who want to destroy
this country.
That language of agitators and anarchists
referring to.
Hi, racist protesters comes directly from
a book called The Camp of the Saints, which
Steven Miller promoted through Briber in 2015
and which is about the destruction of the
white world by brown people described as monsters
and beasts and teeming ants toiling for the
white man's comfort.
And this book explicitly endorses hatred and
violence against people of color as a survival
mechanism.
So it promotes the conspiracy theory of white
genocide that has motivated so many acts of
white supremacist terrorism, including the
El Paso massacre that we saw last August where
twenty three people were killed by a man who
thought he was saving the United States from
a, quote, Hispanic invasion.
It's so, so, so.
So his language is really dog whistling, if
you can even call it.
I don't think it's even necessarily dog whistling.
I think it's directly echoing with the weight
genocide theory.
Are there other examples in terms of Trump's
specific lines?
I mean, early there was, you know, looking
at the origins of America first, then it sounds
relatively benign.
And, you know, how could something just so,
so, so simple a boy have this horrible origin?
So, so to speak.
Are there other examples you think are the
relevant wants to think about?
Yes, sir.
So what a very common recruiting tactic in
white supremacist circles is to use to highlight,
you know, examples of alleged crimes committed
by people of color.
And this is something that Trump has been
doing from the very earliest stages of the
campaign.
And he started out with this sort of more
instinctual, emotional racism, saying that
Mexicans were were criminals and rapists.
But when Steven Miller joined, he he started
to really use very graphic, gory descriptions
of alleged migrant crimes that really works
to incite white fear and white hatred.
And then example being, you know, referring
to migrants, slashing people with machetes
or crushing a woman's eye sockets with a hammer,
you know, butchering little girls language
that is extremely violent and is and is meant
to to provoke, you know, real sense of fear.
That is something that comes from Steven Miller.
Also the use of false migrant crime statistics,
saying that, you know, thousands of Americans
have been murdered by, quote, illegal immigrants.
This is this is false.
You know, immigrants, rather, they come to
this country legally or illegally, are actually
less likely to commit crimes than citizens.
But.
But Trump constantly uses false statistics
about immigrants.
And this is Stephen Miller pulling from the
white supremacist recruiting tactics that
he's familiar websites like American Renaissance,
which he has been, you know, inspired by for
for several years, and which uses this tactic
of highlighting migrant crimes and pumping
out false and misleading crimes.
It takes crime statistics about migrants as
well as black people.
The book is fascinating.
It's called Hate Monger Stephen Miller, Donald
Trump and the White Nationalist Agenda.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Jean Guerrero.
So great to talk to you and I really appreciate
your time.
And the book is excellent.
Thank you so much,